hi John hi so let's keep this this going
this question of how we communicate and
interact on this wonderful space that we
created and are we tolerating each other
are we just using the space for what we
wanted to do before do you you talked
about Wikipedia but what do you think
more January do you think more generally
we're transforming the space we're
starting to I mean you know that I spend
a lot and I know you grew up in Africa I
spent a bunch of time in Africa trying
to get it connected to the Internet and
somewhat successfully by myself and you
know I wanted Brian Eno it said
something that the probe back in the in
the late eighties it's that the problem
with the Internet is there not enough
Africa in it there's still not enough
Africa in it in terms of the culture but
it you know nevertheless is getting
there and and culture you know and other
cultures are starting to be able to
manifest themselves but it's difficult
because so much of what goes on in
cyberspace has to do with language yeah
still and and and so much of what is
really true to a culture is in its own
language you can't you know you can't
have a lingua franca that expresses most
of the things that are unique to that
culture so when you look at these data
that show these the the rate of
linguistic diversification on the web do
you see that as a positive or a negative
absolutely positive I mean there are you
know it's now possible for marginal
languages to actually have a published
so to speak published literature of
significant dimensions but it means
we're not part of on conversation yeah
it does mean that and and and we're
never gonna be but you know we we're
still in the in the process I think of
learning how to be local and global
simultaneously which first of all means
I would guess being in the process of
learning how to think two completely
different ways at once you know which
which we have a difficult time doing in
the West
yeah you know I mean we Emily which
Africans are much more comfortable with
yes I mean if they had to live that way
well it's that way you know I mean you
know it's not either/or it's both and in
every instance it's it's only you know
it was a very useful philosophical and
scientific tool that made it you know
that made possible a great deal of
wonderful development yeah but you know
that the either-or view strikes me as
being completely unhelpful now yeah
everybody yeah yeah I mean the this
there's a huge amount happening in the
create in for example the African
creation of content right and you know
it's part of the whole move around self
representation so on and so forth but it
doesn't seem to it it's difficult to say
that the fact that Africans now self
represent doesn't mean that Westerners
are interested in that they still want
to do their own representation of Africa
and you know and the two things exist
side-by-side on the web apparently not
invariance to each other I mean just as
they did in the other examples he were
giving of you know of you know are we
having are we having a useful debate
about God I mean it's not better not to
even admit the argument you know what I
mean I there's an advanced magazine in
this town and then I used to write for a
lot that the editor came to me at one
point so why don't you start writing for
us again and I said well I don't know
enough about men's shoes I don't think
but and he said well no no no I mean you
know thoughtful stuff and I said well he
said I said well all right maybe he said
well what would you like to write about
and I said I'd like to write about the
information revolution in Brazil because
it didn't happen yeah you know actually
a whole cultural thing didn't happen
because of the government and then and
then the information revolution didn't
happen and now it's happening yeah you
know after it's happened to the grind
I think this is interesting I say yeah
it's happening in a Brazilian way which
is different and I don't know been
following Macchio show about so it's
been doing
I am he's one of my closest friends yeah
sorry yeah I mean we did we talking
about we do a lot together but and I was
thinking I was thinking about Jill you
know I mean and I wanted to write about
you and he looked at me and he said
nothing really interesting ever happens
in the southern hemisphere and I said
what I mean the origin of the human
species I think he's a bit since then
honestly I said okay well it's a redline
zone you know yeah but he meant that
yeah
well this is where in the long term we
all look very foolish don't we I mean
there was a nicely in the short term he
looked very foolish because he then came
back and wanted me to help him get
Joubert Oh she'll do a conference one of
one of the one of the scholars of
medieval Islam said that for many many
many generations Arab scholars debated
why Europeans were so dull and one of
them said you know it's it's not because
of their genetics because when we
enslave them bring them here they
perform quite well it's probably the
climate in that climate is just not
possible to think quickly it's too cold
you know these debates and you can
imagine all that the you know and that's
what you know ultimately cyberspace is
one of those great clouds of that kind
of slashing cultural interaction you
know in hybridization and sometimes it's
working you know I had an inspiring
experience last night do you know who
Manu Chao is yes great fun Manu Chao
played at the war field last night it's
sort of surprising because he's a big
deal in his war fields small place and
what I saw in this audience which was
you know completely heterogeneous in
every conceivable dimension was an Auto
assimilation in all directions it was
the first time I'd been in a big
audience where there were white people
in San Francisco where I could get eye
contact and not see them flinch
now I mean it was it was incredibly
heartwarming and you know just everybody
was speaking about ten languages and
understanding one another yeah so I mean
that can happen I think in the broad and
it seems like some of what you guys are
doing with you know art and culture yeah
I mean he he is any he is an example of
creating this incredibly comfortable
space where every kind of expression can
just flow together yeah that's I was
expecting to see more of that in in you
know in in the web than we see well I
actually had a conversation with him
about this I said you know I think part
of your secret is that you know that
most anger is actually masked sorrow hmm
and he said yes but we must not let
everybody know that and I said but
you're not you don't have an angry
message you don't you don't incite yeah
you don't incite the immune response
yeah he has a transformative he leaves
and what we really need to do is do a
huge amount of immunosuppressive stuff
on our own cultures and our own hearts
and themselves yeah all the time yeah
which means partly understanding immune
response yeah I mean you have to know
first of all you have to know who you
are before you can properly not fear the
other so what is the relationship
between creativity and immune response
well that's it you know I think it's one
of the deepest questions there is
because I think what what most creative
acts do is is probe right into this yeah
into the interstitial surfaces of that
immune response I mean I I like art that
scares the [ __ ] out of ya frankly and
bounce it direction you know it's zero
ranging my mental furniture in a ways
that I have an immune reaction to yeah
yeah it bounces in a different direction
it right and that's you know that's
obviously where what we need to do
because we are you know we're sort of
we're caught in feedback loops that are
not we don't be we're not sounds like
Simon said he said that
understand what your foundation is up to
you know yeah which seems very positive
maybe maybe I miss characterize this but
it seems a very positive way of starting
out with the art and then and then
trying to preserve and you know
strengthen that which comes around it
yeah we try to we try to enable we try
to enable creativity to be a resourceful
fall short and long-term processes of
actually learning and actually you know
in a transformative way and in societies
and particularly you know we so much of
the attention to to issues of diversity
has been a notion of heritage where we
came from which is static which is
static and then you know then we got
obviously a lot of romanticizing about
you know right right I mean and and and
preserving this preserving it in its
little box in its box and you don't ever
climbing out of their box that you put
in and all the rest of it but a
completely different approach thinks
about diversity thinks about
evolutionary processes and resources
creativity and change and we can look
forward actually and what it would take
to create a diversity that actually
works well in a hybridization I mean I
used to be in the cattle business and
let me tell you you know there is such a
thing as hybrid vigor you know oh and
you know you can
it applies as equally to culture as he
has to to genomic behavior yeah well we
work we work with societies that are
so-called traditional indigenous
backward whatever but what we find in
all of those societies is a tremendous
amount of interest in the new in the new
yeah but people want to do it on their
own terms they don't want to do it in a
way which leaves them right ankylosing
under somebody else's control but they
want to experiment with the new and they
find the most incredible in hilarious
ways of experimenting with I have some
friends in and I'm I want to put you
together with these folks there's a some
friends of mine in London called the
October gallery that that do what they
call trans Van Guardian art which they
go to relatively try
vanguardia yeah okay they they go to
relatively traditional cultures like
Papua New Guinea yeah and they find
these sort of young crazy people that
are you know like doing cartoon strips
with satellite characters in Papua you
know pidgin and you know as art I mean
really kind of very advanced edgy
contemporary Papua New Guinean art and
that that sort of thing is you know much
more interesting to me than you know
going out there making certain that this
particular war club is perfectly
preserved yeah well you know the there's
long been a movement among artists in
societies slap-happy New Guinea someone
characterized this as the authentic
versus eccentric but the outside wanted
them to be authentic and they were
trying to be eccentric in their own
cultures that's sort of how immune
response I mean part of immune response
is good because it you know within the
self you know it's self vs. other but
there's also the part of immune response
that regulates the self towards self so
it doesn't just mean the homeobox I mean
on the most rudimentary level if you
know if the gene didn't rewrite itself
more or less accurately it would be kind
of Katie bar the door right away and you
wouldn't get very far but I mean it this
is also true with art I mean you've got
to have some core yeah that goes on
being itself yeah but if it is identical
it's not right exactly and and and you
want to know how to I mean I'm sure you
think about this a lot and I do too
because we're both dealing with
boundary-less conditions of future
creativity yeah how you can maintain a
core of identity that is fundamentally
uh threatened and at the same time have
a really active rich miscegenation going
on on the fringe and I don't think you
know I don't think we even started to
try to figure out how to talk about this
properly because we're so reactive yeah
well the identity main identity
obviously is all
it's been connected with issues of
politics and so on and so forth
that's probably stronger than ever
and most of the artists who are in this
genre are trying to play with identity
of course trying to fail to play with it
Oh play okay yeah and you know but yes
trying to fail the identity test at the
site yeah right exactly
but this is me this is us it's okay Rick
and and they are doing it as individuals
but yet you can also see that their
whole society is engaged in this debate
and part of the identity question
obviously comes back to issues of of
place and livelihood and so oh yeah and
i mean there's and this is one of the
problems with with cyberspace is that
yeah that kind of doesn't matter like it
does in a small town whether it's in
africa or while yeah yeah you can be
almost anything in cyberspace but if you
are living in the mountains of central
asia
you know counts you were for the longest
time you're you became a Soviet citizen
and you were I mean part of the idea was
that you know was that man man and man
and his systems were going to dominate
nature and so you could you didn't have
to go up and down the mountain with the
seasons because you were a Soviet
citizen right and you could get your
subsidy some other places and all the
rest of it but now you no longer part of
the Soviet Union you you can have and I
paid all kinds of things about identity
but you better go up and down the
mountain because actually you know
that's the situation so you've got to
build a culture that enables you to go
back up and down the mountain at the
same time as you have infinite
flexibility and possibility about sort
of thinking of yourself as a Eurasian
and any night playing the cymbals and
not being too irritable about it if you
can possibly do it I mean yeah or here I
mean irritating yeah
it's uh it's it I mean I guess it's just
life among the humans in some respects
it's that it's you know it was it was
bad enough when it was village politics
and now that we have like six point
seven billion of us arguing it's it's a
mess
yeah what are gonna do about politics
well you know one of the things I
thought would happen you know as I say I
thought the you know the the existing
structure of you know the Machine notion
of organizing human affairs was going to
collapse what I wasn't really
considering would be that we'd have to
go through the current period where all
of those structures would still be
intact in a way but fibrillating
yeah you know quivering and and like all
fibrillating organs consuming huge
amounts of energy and and and resources
yeah and not actually putting much out
and incapable of doing so in fact and we
don't have yet start started in any kind
of useful way I mean I don't think
Burning Man is the model by which we
want to replace the federal government
unlike some people but you know we do
not have we have not figured out how to
take the self-organizing properties of
the internet and start to use it to
organize themselves in a political
fashion without participating much too
much in something that you know is
actually in many ways a moribund
conversation that we we need to engage
with but we need to figure out ways to
disengage with it
it's not a very clear answer but I mean
it's well this is a this is an ugly
phase yeah and it's not we are not the
only people looking for the answers to
this I mean I've been very struck by how
successfully you know pretty nasty
people
you know groups of pretty nasty
political ends use the Internet to
mobilize oh absolutely you know very
generous forces it's a demagogues
paradise yeah I mean you can
it is a absolutely brilliant place for
free spouting inflammatory nonsense we
knew that it was right but we just
thought it would be more self corrected
I mean you know we could go back to the
to the to the massacres in the Great
Lakes region in the print you know in
the previous decade the radio was you
know the immobilizer but we work in in
in Kobe Republic and there the internet
was a very very powerful tool and
deliberately used tool to construct
fearful rhetoric and to document things
that often didn't happen in ways to
mobilize us back and could against
communities against each other so well I
mean it's a you know it's a poor workman
who blames his tools I mean we will you
know that the internet is not even a
tool it's just it's just an environment
in which we might speak and we're still
responsible for what we say and it's a
space for this limited creature the
human being yeah and we are marvelous
bit flawed it's a good thing I like the
human comedy because there's been plenty
of it to appreciate anyway thank you
thank you for what you're doing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you